des républicains la parole est à
monsieur sylvain berrios monsieur le
premier ministre
hier la moitié de votre gouvernement à
traverser le périphérique pour se rendre
en banlieue faire des annonces souvent
réchauffer d'ailleurs avant de regagner
immédiatement leurs ministères du 7ème
arrondissement pour des raisons
politiciennes vous avez décidé de punir
les maires qui avec le soutien de leurs
populations ont choisi de préserver leur
cadre de vie en proposant des logements
sociaux à taille humaine est bien
intégré monsieur le premier ministre
ce n'est pas la hauteur de la situation
ce n'est pas en punissant telle ou telle
ville que l'on vivra mieux dans les
quartiers les plus défavorisés
ce que les français attendent ce n'est
pas une liste noire des villes carences
et c'est une liste d'or des quartiers
dans lesquels vous devez mobiliser les
moyens de l'état
les français ne veulent pas de ces deux
france de ces deux républiques que vous
opposez avec cynisme mépris et à
tolérance gouverner ce n'est pas soufflé
sur les braises de la tolérance et
s'étonner ensuite que l' incendie se
propage
gouverner c'est agir avec conviction et
détermination
ce n'est pas chercher en toute occasion
un bouc émissaire pour reporter les
échecs du passé
croyez vous vraiment qu'en sanctionnant
des mères qui ne partagent pas votre
opinion vous allez régler les problèmes
d'insécurité de violence de logement
d'éducation d'emploi d'intégration et de
drogue dans les quartiers difficiles
monsieur le premier ministre croyez vous
vraiment qu'au lendemain de vos annonces
des habitants de ces quartiers vivront
mieux
monsieur le premier ministre dix ans
après les émeutes que la france a subi
croyez vous vraiment que vos annonces
portent un espoir pour les français
merci monsieur berrios la parole et à
madame la ministre du logement de
l'égalité des territoires et la ruralité
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
sylvain berrios mais quelle mauvaise foi
quelle malhonnêteté
lorsqu'on entend votre question oui ce
gouvernement a agi avec détermination
pour faire du logement du logement
social et de la mixité sociale
une de ses priorités mais puisque votre
temps et était polémique permettez moi
monsieur le député de rappeler quelques
chiffres
quelques chiffres qui concernent une
commune que vous connaissez bien dans
votre commune 7 % de logements sociaux
votre commune a été quatre fois carence
est successivement depuis l'entrée en
vigueur de la loi sru dans un territoire
qui compte pourtant plus de 394 me le
demandeurs de logements sociaux dans
notre pays compte 1 million 700 mille de
demandeurs de logements sociaux oui il
nous faut agir et que dire de votre
comportement monsieur le député maire
lorsque vous avez décidé de mettre en
vente des logements communaux vacants et
que vous avez refusé de transmettre la
déclaration d'intention d'aliéner alors
que l'état avait manifesté son intention
de préempter pour construire des
logements sociaux
voilà monsieur le député des raisons
pour laquelle dans les 36 communes que
nous avons dévoilé hier l'état souhaite
reprendre la main pour délivrer les
permis de construire pour préempter les
terrains communaux pour mobiliser le
parc privé parce que c'est cela la
mixité sociale c'est cela l'égalité des
territoires
et ce n'est pas en ayant un comportement
égoïste en ne permettant pas à nos
concitoyens de se loger dignement que
vous en aurez la république
merci madame un ministre